acompañarnos
pensar cuántas historias de lo que
hacemos
porque nosotros hacemos nuestro trabajo
25 más por la calle
bueno
no solamente les insultan si no les
aprenderé a esos chicos son pareja
esos novios son homosexuales
una persona trans intenta entrar a un
restaurante y le dice
no puede entrar porque no hacer las
personas atrás
igualmente una persona de los actuales
de la cruz y le dicen aquí no aceptamos
personas como tú
mi nombre ramírez soy
esta activista de derechos humanos y
esencialmente en este momento de mi vida
estoy dedicando muchísimas cosas para
trabajar con los derechos de la
diversidad sexual
eso que ven ustedes allí no es la clave
de un wifi es un acrónimo que sintetiza
un montón de orientaciones sexuales e
identidades de género que históricamente
ha sido la extremidad
en este momento yo puedo hablar en
nombre de este grupo y el nombre del
grupo en situación de vulnerabilidad de
derechos humanos y que podemos decir los
con muchísimas penas más somos
las historias que les contaban no
pasaron en eeuu no pasaron
un país del medio árabe pasado
esto nos supone una cantidad de restos
sociales que tienen que ver con cómo
construir un futuro en medio de un
contexto complejo
como saben ustedes de contexto países no
solamente es completa dramático
y hay gente que nos pregunta por qué
ustedes están siendo trabajando por
estas cosas que presentaron el primer
mundo en un momento donde la gente se
está muriendo de hambre de donde los
hospitales
de bordado donde no hay insumos para
nada pareciera que me hacen esa pregunta
entienden este país nos entienden a
nosotros como una cosa al margen
la comunidad del 93 nos parece equipo si
no no son parte del país
porque no tenemos la misma los mismos
derechos que supone tener una ciudad
[Música]
de avanzar me gustaría probablemente
algunos han tenido algún acercamiento
con este peronismo
otros definitivamente no hay algunos
conocerán algunas de estas letras
hoy estamos en un hombre de hombres de
piernas de personas gays de personas
bisexuales y personas transgénero
transexuales y travestis de personas
intersexuales y de personas de personas
cuyas
todas las personas que se identifiquen
algunas de estas identidades
orientaciones en venezuela no tienen
derechos las personas
no tenemos la posibilidad de construir
un plan de vida en venezuela en este
momento se habla muchísimo del fenómeno
migratorio
pero fenómeno migratorio en la
diversidad sexual
para nosotros poder construir un plan de
vida era un montón de derecho que
tenemos que ir
cuando les comentaba las historias de
violencia me gustaría a partir del hecho
de
digamos que enraíza tanto odio como para
querer eliminar o despertar algo
distinto
el fenómeno de la discriminación como
todos sabemos no es exclusivo de la
población del fbi también lo viven las
mujeres también personas
afrodescendientes lo viven los migrantes
no solamente quienes están yendo un
momento o país de inmigrantes venían y
tampoco tenían acceso a ciertos derechos
ni reconocimientos del último
la discriminación también la viven los
niños los nativos y me gustaría pensar
en estos proyectos de ciudad que estamos
haciendo si tenemos un enfoque para
incluir para construir tejido social
quiero que hablemos un poquito de la
violencia y de que supone discriminación
exactamente
hay una tendencia generalizada en la
región estos son datos de la corte
intermedia del informe de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos que
habla en venezuela no tenemos cifras
oficiales de cuántas personas son
asesinadas violentadas
en razón de orientación sexual e
identidad de género
tampoco la población el efecto se siente
seguro en ir a denunciar porque eso
también supone una doble vulnerabilidad
o bien que las instituciones nos
rechacen las instituciones se burle o
bien que reafirmen la evidencia
tampoco estamos hablando una violencia
generalizada cuando se habla de la
discriminación contra el g20 que se cree
solamente que tienen que ver con
negación del derecho al matrimonio
igualitario o por negación de un marco
jurídico
la comunidad de estructura
estaba presente en todos los niveles de
nuestra vida y empieza en la casa se
realiza en la escuela se replica en la
calle
y finalmente se va replicando en todos
los espacios de la vida pública
partiendo de esa realidad
tenemos que hacer es hacer algo
no supone que sea una tarea exclusiva de
los afectados
la violencia contra el helvético está
muy conectada
con problemas históricos con por razones
religiosas con razones pseudocientíficas
por razones políticas y también con
razones antropológicas históricas
incluso anthropos en donde la idea de lo
masculino y lo de la heterosexualidad
son lo único válido en nuestra sociedad
y eso supone acceder a un montón de
derechos y privilegios que no tienen lo
que sean distintos a los angolinos con
la idea antropocéntrica donde el hombre
toma decisión
el hombre masculino
volviendo a las violencias hay otras
cosas como una invisibilidad de la
violencia cotidiana
venezuela por ejemplo me podrían
asesinar por ser homosexual y en el
informe médico probablemente la empresa
va a salir que fui asesinado en un
crimen pasional o que me lo va a robar
[Música]
hay altísimos niveles de tu verdad de
eso dan cuenta casi todos los informes
que tocan la violencia contra el héroe
cuando hablamos de altísimo nivel de
crueldad nos referimos que no solamente
de asesinatos sino que ocurren con
ensañamiento hay un caso no más parte
una persona fue asesinada donde lo
sexual fue asesinado por con 99
puñaladas
igualmente estamos hablando de cosas
como apedrear a alguien por ir a ganar
hay muchísima violencia como represalia
a demostraciones de efecto público en
parejas homosexuales
y por la calle supone no solamente
violencia física sino violencia
violencia sexual incluso acoso verbal
y bueno hay muchísimas violaciones del
derecho a la vida
y casi todos
les decía que estos son esta es la punta
de la ética pero no hay
una mirada clara de la violencia o lo
que llamamos nosotros las violencias
simbólicas
que tienen que ver con aquellas
violencias que se ejercen contra ciertos
grupos para ejercer dominio
o invisibilidad como afinación y son tan
imperceptibles que
ya en nuestra sociedad apareció en
normalizar un ejemplo podría ser el
chiste muy común que a través del chiste
es que se ejerza violencia contra los
hombres homosexuales sobre todos los
hombres como sexuales afeminados y eso
responde también a aquella mirada de
desprecio hacia lo femenino
como movimientos primero tenemos partir
del hecho de que si no me siento
profundamente orgulloso de la comunidad
les ve de cuba y del movimiento por los
derechos civiles
primero porque nosotros hemos decidido
las soluciones o enfrentar la violencia
no respondiendo con más violencia sino
saliendo exigente
y saliendo exigir justicia eso ya supone
para nosotros el primer triunfo
como como movimiento sea
lo segundo
es decir que no podemos simplificar la
lucha igualitaria solamente con el tema
del matrimonio igualitario o con el
pedir que no nos maten
entonces no hay que matarle la mirada
como bueno de algo apoyo y que no nos
maten pero realmente hay
un montón de exigencias detrás de este
movimiento que efectivamente tienen que
ver un matrimonio igualitario que
donde el exigimos el estado de
reconocimiento a las parejas del mismo
sexo acceder a los mismos derechos que
las parejas heterosexuales
cuando el estado se niega a cumplir los
mandatos de las casi todos tratados
internacionales en materia de derechos
humanos que dan cuenta de que el
matrimonio igualitario el derecho humano
ya no hay dudas con eso ya no hay nada
opinable con respecto a eso el
matrimonio igualitario en derechos
humanos
cuando el estado se niega a reconocer
garantizar y proteger ese derecho
hay 35 derechos inherentes que el estado
de un solo golpe de un solo sofá
exigimos también la ley de identidad de
género el reconocimiento de las personas
trans en este momento
la sigla o como sexual a las personas
homosexuales
bisexuales
están discriminadas en venezuela las
personas trans no tienen acceso ni
siquiera a la identidad
es fundamental
al negar el derecho básico a la
identidad ese derecho fundamental el
estado niega un montón de derechos que
son cruciales
el derecho incluso el marco del contexto
humanitario durante mucho tiempo en
venezuela para acceder a alimentos
solamente se podía hacer a través de una
huella una huella y una serie de las
personas trans no tenían excesos
solamente por no tener una identidad que
les reconociera
tal como lo pide siguiente alguien
hay otras cosas como la creación de
ambientes escolares que no sean
violentos y que sean inclusivos que
reconozcan los derechos de niños niñas y
adolescentes diversos
las escuelas son
los principales focos de violencia
contra las comunidades verdes
incluso muchísimas de las personas trans
sobre todo son eliminadas en un punto
entre las niñas y la pubertad son
eliminados del sistema educativo bien
sea porque lo decide el personal docente
o el personal directivo o bien porque
los ambientes son tan hostiles
hoy quieren las personas que quieren
salirse y para sobrevivir
algunas personas no sobreviven empresas
muchísimos niveles de suicidios
las personas del efecto en general para
las personas trans sobre todo el
suicidio está muy presente para contarle
aproximarles el promedio de vida de una
persona atrás en venezuela y en
latinoamérica mejor dicho no llega
estamos además exigiendo un marco
jurídico que reconozca derechos en este
momento en venezuela no hay ninguna ley
donde aparezca el acrónimo el efecto
se habla por aquí de orientación sexual
de la no discriminación por la
orientación sexual
pero no hay una ley
nacionales que reconozcan el eje como
persona
y eso lo grande
otra cosa que exigimos es la negación de
de operaciones arbitrarias irreversibles
contra personas intersexuales
y también sistemas de salud y de
educación que estén orientados hacia
o que puedan prestar atención
diferenciada hacia la comunidad
son muchísimas exigencias las que hay en
este momento en la posición del estado
de no ofrecer derechos a nadie
en eso y en ese derecho para ninguno
estamos incluidos nosotros
en nuestro movimiento que tiene un
enfoque estadal nosotros lo que estamos
apostando también por la construcción
nacional
una ciudad más de construir ciudad en un
contexto donde el odio es la norma es un
reto monumental
construir ciudad no solamente tiene que
ver con la infraestructura tiene que ver
también con tejido social
y en este momento donde venezuela tienen
profundas medidas
complejas vidas que hay que empezar a
trabajar
y decirles que las personas
tuvimos violencia en casa
y sin embargo somos un ejemplo en muchos
sentidos para el país
nosotros hemos aprendido el chelsea
mundial y hemos sobre todo hemos
aprendido a perdonar a perdonar a padres
que nos de expresión a perdonar para ser
golpeados al profesor que nos humillaba
a los compañeritos que nos odiaban y eso
creo que puede servir de lección para un
país que requiere grandísimas lecciones
en materia de reconciliación y de
reconstrucción
nosotros estamos apostando por la
construcción de una medida igualitaria
por la construcción de una medida que
tenga derecho para todo para todos y
para todos y en ese sentido estamos
obligados a seguir tendiendo puentes con
sectores con los cuales podamos convivir
la convivencia no supone
estar hoy
o compartir con personas distintas
personas iguales los fáciles esenciales
de poder compartir con quien piense
igual a nosotros con quién es igual a
nosotros realmente la convivencia tiene
que ver con aprender a compartir a
reconocer diferente
de otra forma seguimos
creando ciudadanía al margen nuestro
bueno el gran reto de nuestro movimiento
y el reto que los involucra usted es
empezar a trabajar por la inclusión
social y por una medida donde todos
tengamos
[Aplausos]